LAURENCE MORONEY: Our last
session of the day on Firebase.
I'm Laurence Moroney
[SPEAKING CHINESE].
And so I'm going to be
talking about Firebase Cloud
Messaging and Firebase
Notifications,
and some of the
technologies that we
have in Firebase for you
to deliver notifications
to your end users.
It's quite a short
talk, and there's
going to be a few
demos in there as well.
And I'm going to try and
make the demos interactive,
so I'm going to need
your help with them.
To get started, talking a little
bit about what notifications
are and some of the technologies
that we have at Google.
So how many of you have heard
of Firebase Notifications?
Not many.
And how about Firebase Cloud
Messaging or Google Cloud
Messaging?
Not many more.
OK, interesting.
So I'm going to start with
Firebase Notifications.
And the idea behind
Firebase Notifications
is that we wanted to give you
a technology that you could use
to deliver real time
notifications to your end users
without you requiring to
build any kind of server
infrastructure to do so.
So if you use Firebase,
we have a thing
at Firebase called the
Firebase Console that you
might be familiar with.
And the Firebase Console
is used for things
like analytics and crash
reporting, and all that.
And within the Firebase
Console, you're
given a user
interface that allows
you to define the notification
that you send to your users,
and importantly, and
perhaps more importantly,
pick the population of
users that you're going
to send that notification to.
So this is a really
useful technology,
I think, for the business
side of your house.
So people who are not
developers, people
who are marketers, people
who a business group,
that kind of thing,
who don't want
to deal with actually writing
a server or managing a server.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAURENCE MORONEY: The
music's still going.
[CHUCKLING] I want
to start dancing.
You don't want to build a server
and all that kind of thing
for managing these
notifications,
but just have a very simple
interface that they could go in
and they can select an audience
based on analytics to whom they
would deliver notifications.
And then on the client
side, within your app,
be it an Android app or
an iOS app or a web app,
we want to make it
as simple as possible
for you to be able to receive
these notifications that they
can be then used to
re-engage with your app.
Most users, I'm trying to
remember the statistics,
but the average user has
about 35 apps on their device.
And the vast majority
of these apps
are not used more than one time.
So as a result, you have a lot
of these apps on your device.
They're sitting
there on your device.
They've been installed, and
they've been forgotten about.
And you as an app
developer, that's
terrible, because you spent
so much time and effort
building your app,
marketing your app,
getting people to install it.
They use it once and then
they forget about it.
So what we wanted to do
is provide notifications,
so that when a user
receives a notification,
it will allow them to
re-engage with your app,
and relaunch your app, and
remember and rediscover
your app.
Now, this obviously
is very easily open
to misuse, where somebody
could spam users and send
too many notifications to
users and turn users off.
So what we wanted
to do was give you
very powerful tools that will
allow you to select your user
population that you're going
to send notifications to
so that you don't oversend.
These notifications are
driven off of analytics,
as I mentioned.
And the analytics
tools in Firebase
are very powerful to
the extent of say,
for example, you have an
e-commerce application
that you could find
a population of users
of your e-commerce
application as people
who have made a purchase
in the last 30 days
but have not made a
purchase in the 60 days
prior to that, as in
these are customers
that you've had for a while
and are now using your app,
and you want to get
them using your app
or continuing to use your app.
And those kind of people you can
use then to find a population.
You can send a
notification to them
to say, hey, thanks
for using our app,
here's a 20% discount code,
something along those lines.
And as a result, you have this
very powerful re-engagement
of your users.
And notifications,
to me, is primarily
about re-engaging
your users, keeping
them interested in
your app, keeping
them exciting to use your
app, and growing your app
as a result.
My bottom bullet here,
which is my favorite part,
I think, of using
Firebase Notifications is
that there's actually no code
necessary on the client side.
So if you're building
an Android app,
you have a built
out Gradle file,
and this is what you put in
your built out Gradle file.
That's it.
You don't find any code
whatsoever within your app
itself.
You just tell your app
to use com/google/fireb
ase/firebasemessaging and
whatever the current version
number is or whatever the latest
version is, and that's it.
You will get notifications
within your app.
I'm a very lazy developer,
and as a result,
I really like this.
Again, if you're
building an app,
if you're building an app
for the international market,
and you want to give
your users, and you
want to give your
business the facility
to allow re-engagement
with your users,
this is all you have to do.
Pretty simple, right?
And this is what
the console will
look like, the Firebase
Console, when you're doing that.
So here, I have it
linked with Analytics.
So I've set up Analytics, and
there's a notifications funnel.
So in this case, there's
an app called Bingo Blast.
And there was a notification
so that, you know, level
up at Bingo Blast
to unlock new codes
that was sent out to people.
So they said, hey, if I continue
playing this game Bingo Blast,
and if I level up, I'm
going to get some goodies
beyond leveling up.
This notification was
sent out, as you can see,
on the 9th of August 2016.
It was sent to
the Android users,
and it was targeting
between 1 and 10,000 users.
And then you can see the
effectiveness of that here.
Well, what we can
see in this case,
we sent this many notifications.
This many were opened, and this
many were actually acted on.
So it's a pretty sharp
drop-off in this case,
because not everybody
will interact
with every notification.
And I think it's
really good for you
to get that kind of intelligence
behind your notifications.
Because here this tells
me that the notification
that we used here was a
very bad one, because we
sent that many and we got that
many converted, very, very few.
Why do you think this
notification would be bad?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
LAURENCE MORONEY: What's that?
Sorry.
AUDIENCE: The
message was useless.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Yeah.
The message wasn't good.
It's kind of a useless
message, right?
Instead of saying,
hey, if you level up,
you're going to get
more of the game.
Because people who
are leveling up
are people who are
playing the game anyway,
so why would they
want to do this?
What if it was a case of,
hey, remember Bingo Blast?
If you play it now, we're going
to give you 500 free coins.
Now that kind of notification
would be very powerful,
and that's the idea
behind analytics.
So you can use analytics
to define your audience,
and then you can use
analytics within notifications
to understand how things work.
So beyond the programming and
beyond the ease of programming,
I just love the fact that we've
got analytics on both sides--
prior to sending
the notification,
so you could pick your
audience, and then after sending
the notification, so
that you can know what
your audience has done.
My clicker isn't working.
Can I go to the next slide?
The clicker has failed.
There we go.
So earlier, I showed a
piece of code that says,
OK, in my application, if I just
want to receive a notification,
and then I will touch
on that notification
and it relaunches my app, then
if the application was running
in the background, I'm going to
get my application relaunched.
But sometimes, we might
want to go like a little bit
more complex, and we want
to write some code that
allows me to do something
a little bit more
interesting with
that notification,
maybe take me to a specific
screen within my application
once the user has
touched the notification.
And for that, you need
a little bit of code.
And this is what it
looks like in Android.
So in Android, I've created
a service class called--
in this case, it's
MyFirebaseMessagingService.
And I've told it, on an action
of a Firebase Messaging event,
use this service.
So this is something that
goes into my Android manifest.
Can I go to the
next slide, please?
And then within my code
within my Android manifest,
it's going to look
something like thi-- sorry,
within my messaging
service, it's
going to look
something like this.
I've created a class.
You saw it named in the
previous slide called
MyFirebaseMessagingService.
And in this case,
Firebase offers you
this class called
FirebaseMessagingService
that you can extend.
What this does is this
messaging service then
provides an onMessageReceived,
so that when
Firebase Notifications sends
that message and the device
receives that message,
this event will get logged.
This event will get
fired, and then I
can do whatever I want
to within this event.
So, for example, upon receiving
a notification and the user
touches the location,
and I want to go--
for example, if
it's a game, if I
want to go to a special
screen where the user gets 500
free coins or
something like that,
I can do so instead of
just launching them back
into where the were
in the application.
Can I go forward again, please?
I don't know why my
clicker has failed.
It's probably the batteries out.
And forward again.
Can we switch to
the demo machine?
So let me show a demo of this.
I'm going to put the
mic down for a second.
So to show a demo of this, I
have a tablet running here.
And you've just seen
my unlock code--
[LAUGHS] those of you
who are paying attention.
So on the tablet, I've
written this application
that I call Firebase
Notification 1.
And if you're familiar
with Android Studio,
in Android Studio,
you have the ability
to just say File, New,
Single Activity Application.
And that's all this is.
So when you create that single
activity application in Android
Studio, you get this.
And it says
"HelloWorld" at the top.
So I haven't done
anything to that,
except adding that single
line to the built out Gradle
that I spoke about.
So I'm going to put that app
in the background for a moment.
And now, over here, I'm
in the Firebase Console.
And in the Firebase Console,
I can compose a message
that I'm going to
send to that app.
So a lot of times when I demo
something like this people
think, oh, he's
prerecorded something
and he's precanned something.
So I want you to
help me craft what
this message is going to be so
that you know that it's real.
Anybody want to-- any
sports friends here?
Wow.
No.
OK.
Anybody want to give me a
message that I'm going to send?
Merry Christmas or Happy
New Year or Welcome Beijing?
So if I-- whoops,
I typed it wrong.
My Chinese typing's
not very good.
So if I type something like
"Welcome Beijing," so this now,
I'm not a programmer.
I'm not a developer.
Maybe I'm a marketer
or something like this.
I have this tool, and this tool,
I can specify the message text.
Now, maybe this
message text isn't
the best for notifying someone,
but I'm going to use it anyway.
And then when I target
it, I can target
a number of different things.
So I can target an entire
user segment, which
has been defined by analytics.
I can target a topic.
I'm going to talk about
Cloud Messaging in a moment,
but in Cloud Messaging, you
can define areas called Topics.
So, for example, if you're-- the
example I used this morning is
like say you're building
an application for airport
information.
You live here in
Beijing, and say, you
could create a topic
for Beijing airport.
So all notifications
that go to the topic
Beijing airports, then anybody
who's interested in that topic
would subscribe to it.
So in this case,
I could just say,
go to that topic, name the
topic the Beijing Airport topic,
and then every user who's
receiving the notification
are the users who actively
subscribed to that topic.
I can also target it to a single
device, as you can see there.
Or I could pick
a particular app.
So here within my Firebase
project, I've build three apps.
There's an Android one
called Firebase Notification
1, which is what was
running over there.
There's another called
Firebase Notification
2, which I'll show in a moment.
And there's an iOS one called
iOS Firebase Notification 1.
But I'm just going to
select-- whoops, I missed.
I'm going to select
Firebase Notification 1.
And then I'm going to come down
here and say, send a message.
So then the message,
hey, look, it's
just asking me to review it.
When I press this Send
button in a moment,
keep your eye on the
top notification bar
just under where it says
Nexus 7 on my tablet,
and you'll see that
notification. arrive.
So I press Send.
There's the notification.
It has arrived already.
So if I swipe
down, it's probably
kind of hard to
see on the monitor,
but you can see that
top notification,
Firebase Notification
1, Welcome Beijing,
that I typed in a moment ago.
You saw how quickly
that arrived.
And then when I touch
on the notification,
the application relaunches.
So here's a great way
to re-engage your users
through simple notification.
In this case, I sent it out
to every instance of this app,
because there's really
only one or two instances.
It's just running on my devices.
But if you've got an install
base of thousands of users,
then you could use the filtering
that I showed earlier on.
You could use the analytics
filtering to do so.
Now, one question
that I always get
when I do that demo is that
people will then ask, OK,
that's all very nice, but when
you relaunched the application,
you relaunched it
into the activity
that you were looking
at earlier on.
What if I want to drive
the content of the activity
based on the content
of the notification?
Well, that code that
I showed a moment ago,
where I wrote that simple
service, so I built that
into this application.
So this one, Firebase
Notification 2,
is exactly the same.
It's just the File,
New, Single View
Activity within Android Studio.
I added the Firebase
Notifications to it.
And in this case, I also added
that service that I mentioned.
So I'm going to
create a new message.
And I'm going to
send it to that one.
So can someone help
me craft a message?
What should I put in here?
Shout something out.
AUDIENCE: Have a nice day.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Have a nice day.
I'm going to put the
mic down to type.
So I've just typed out "have
a nice day," as you asked.
And now I'll go down
here, and in this case,
I'm going to say send it
to Firebase Notification 2.
As you saw, I picked it there.
It's cropped off, sorry.
But if you see it
here on the menu,
I'm just saying pick to send
to firebasenotification2,
because this app is
Firebase Notification 2.
So I'll pick that, and
I'll say Send message.
And, again, it's
asking me to review it.
Keep your eye on the tablet,
on the left-hand side.
That when I hit Send,
the message will come in.
And now, what happened is
once the message arrived,
you see I didn't
interact with it.
I didn't touch it or anything.
Because the app was
actually active,
when the message arrived,
the messaging service
picked up that message.
You asked me to say
"have a nice day."
And all this activity does in
this simple one is just render
that text that was
in the notification.
So it was really
as easy as that.
All I had to do
to build this one
to actually receive
the notification,
launch the new
activity in response
to it, was link in
Firebase Notifications,
and then as well
as far as Firebase
Notifications to create that
messaging service that I showed
the source code for and have
that messaging service launch
this activity and just render
this text in the activity.
So can we switch back
to slides, please?
So that's the kind
of thing that you can
do with Firebase Notifications.
It makes it very,
very simple for you
to create these
notifications that you can
use to re-engage your users.
And again, thinking
in terms of you've
spent all this time and
effort building an app,
you've spent all this time
and effort marketing it,
you don't want that app to
be forgotten when people have
installed it and
it's sitting there
as one of those dozens
of apps that they've only
ever used once.
And notifications,
when you're smart,
they can help you avoid that.
So Cloud Messaging,
it lets you then
take this to the next level.
So with Cloud
Messaging, you can send
messages, like I mentioned,
to topics, to users,
and all that kind of stuff.
We actually-- as of now, we're
sending in the infrastructure
of Cloud Messaging, Google,
we're seeing trillions
of messages per week
actually being sold--
being sent.
And these messages, generally
for connected devices,
will arrive in less
than half a second, so
500 milliseconds or
less, many of them
even less than 250 milliseconds.
So they're arriving
very quickly.
As you saw when I
demoed there, and that's
using the Wi-FI
in the room here,
they were arriving very quickly.
With Cloud Messaging, you start
getting some more functionality
that wouldn't be
possible with the console
here in notifications,
such as upstream messages.
So you saw me receiving a
message from the Firebase
Notifications, but
I could build my app
when I'm using Cloud Messaging
to send upstream messages too.
So, for example, maybe
in response to a message
that I received, I could
send something back.
This could be used
for chat rooms.
This could be used for
peer-to-peer chat, all
of those kinds of things.
And Topics, as I
mentioned earlier on,
are also supported in
Firebase Cloud Messaging.
So when you build your
messaging, your app, or when
you build something that uses
Firebase Cloud Messaging,
you get all of these benefits.
Now, to build this is
a little more complex.
So as you saw already when
I was using notifications,
all of my notifications I was
generating on the Firebase
Console, and Google was nice
enough to build that for me.
But with Firebase
Cloud Messaging,
there's a little bit
more that you have to do.
And with Firebase Cloud
Messaging, that generally means
you have to build an
app server yourself.
And this app server
can be very simple.
And the reason why
you need this is
that when a user registers
with Firebase Cloud Messaging,
your app will receive a server
ID, all for Firebase Messaging,
that identifies that device.
It doesn't identify personal
information about the user,
but it's used to address
that specific device.
So when you have
those registration IDs
for each of the devices that
your users are actually using,
you need to know
how you're going
to send messages to these IDs.
So the next thing
that you'll do,
and this is where I'm saying
you'll need an app server,
is their app will generally
tell your app server,
here's my registration ID that
Google Firebase has given me,
please keep track of it.
So then your app server will
have a simple database perhaps
that will store your
registration ID, your Firebase
ID, and you store that
on your app server.
And now your app server will
tell Firebase Cloud Messaging
the message is to send
to apps on your behalf.
So, for example, you could
build a console here,
like the Firebase Console
that you give access
to your business people, or your
marketing people, or whatever.
Or you can build code within
your app or your site that
then talks to your
app server and says,
send this message to this
topic, send this message
to this device,
send this message
to this group of devices.
And then your app server would
actually service that message.
And how it services
that message is
it knows the IDs that the
message is supposed to go to,
or it knows the topic that the
message is supposed to go to.
And then Firebase
Cloud Messaging,
this black box over here, has an
API that your server will call.
And then your server will
say, here's my API key.
I'm authenticating myself.
I'm this person's application.
Please send this
message to this topic.
Please send this message
to these devices,
and stuff like that.
And then, as a
result, you've just
built a messaging
infrastructure that
has all the attributes that
I mentioned earlier on.
So let's give a quick of
this and what it looks like.
Now, this is a
live demo so if you
take a look at
the URL at the top
there, if you have a browser,
or a laptop, or something open,
you can go visit now.
And if you type in a
message it will send to it.
It will actually
appear on my watch.
So a lot of time,
I ask people, hey,
if you want to
ask questions or--
sometimes this backfires.
I did this talk
recently in Germany,
and people got the URL,
and then my watch just
kept buzzing for the
rest of the talk,
and I couldn't
concentrate on what
I was supposed to be saying.
But the idea is this is an
app server like the ones
that I mentioned in
the previous diagram.
I can show the
PHP code that this
was written in in a moment.
These big strings that you
see here are the Firebase IDs.
So what's happened
is this tablet
I've registered
with this website.
The applications right here.
It's, again, a very simple app.
It's just got a single button
on it that says Register.
When I touch that
button, the app
is calling Firebase, getting
an instance ID for this device,
sending that instance
ID up to my server.
The instance ID looks
something like this.
And then on my server, I just
created a simple PHP page
that says for each instance ID,
I can type something and send
it to that device
individually, or this top one,
I can type something and
send it to all devices that
are actually registering.
And right now, I
have seven devices
registered on this page.
So if I go in and
type something--
give me something
to say, anybody?
AUDIENCE: Someone has
broken into your house.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Someone
has broken into your house.
Wow.
I would have never
thought of that one.
Someone has broken
into your house.
And if I send that--
[DING]
You probably heard the ding.
And it's going to show up.
Yep, and here it is.
It's showing up on
my watch-- "someone
has broken into your house."
So I can see why
you picked that one.
Hopefully my wife isn't
registered on the same thing,
and now she's going
to call me panicking.
[CHUCKLING]
So the idea behind this is
that, again, it's very simple,
this website.
And, again, if you--
oh, somebody's doing it.
Yeah, somebody just
sent me a message.
I'm not going to answer it.
So if you go onto this website,
and all this website is doing
is this is a MYSQL database.
The MYSQL database is storing
these registration IDs.
This page is reading
that database,
writing out HTML for
each of these IDs,
and writing out HTML
for each of these forms,
and then creating
another form here in HTML
so that when somebody
types a message,
if I type in the
top box, it reads
from MySQL all of the
seven IDs, and tells
FCM to send that message
to each of those seven IDs.
Or if I do it in one of
these individual boxes,
it's telling FCM to
send it to that one.
So let's take a look
at the code for that
and how that actually looks.
So first of all, if I open
this one, you can see this is--
I was just using MYSQL.
I was using what's
called My PHP Admin.
So if I go into My
PH Admin-- and I
took this screenshot earlier on.
This is just my database.
If you've ever written
MYSQL databases,
if you're familiar
with My PHP Admin,
you'll see this is what it is.
I just stored two fields
in here at the time
that I created the record and
the actual registration ID
in FCM.
That's it.
It's as simple as that.
So now, if I go back
to-- let's take a look
at some of the source code.
And if anybody wants
this source code,
I'm more than happy
to share it with you.
So if I go homepage.php
first, can you read that?
No, that's too small.
Let me make it bigger.
So if I look at
this source code,
I don't know how easy
it is for you to read.
Hopefully you can see it.
So in this case, all this
source code is doing,
this is the page that I
showed you a moment ago.
And what I'm doing
here is that I just
have a number of HTML forms.
And in this case,
you can see this form
is called [? AllForm ?] here,
and the method is to Post.
And all I'm doing
on this form is
when I get that Send button
I'm going to post this form,
and when I post this
form, it's going
to call another PHP module.
And as we can see here, that
was called [INAUDIBLE] .php,
and then telling it the message
and telling it the registration
ID or the list of
registration IDs.
So if we look at
that code in PHP,
that's where the magic happens.
And it's as simple as this.
So at the top, you
can see there's a URL.
And the URL is
fcm.googleapis.com/fcm/send.
So as you can imagine
from the name of the URL,
that's the URL.
That's the endpoints
that FCM has given me
to allow me to send messages.
So then there's a
number of headers
that you need when
you're calling that one.
The top one is my
authorization key.
So this authorization key
he is telling Firebase
that it really is me
sending it so that you
can't send to my devices.
Or if somebody is using
my app, and they've
registered with
my device ID, you
can't send to them, like
a competitor of mine,
or a pirate, or a
hacker, or something
can't send to devices
using my app unless they
have this authorization key.
So the authorization
key is how you're
telling us that this
is who you really are.
So I'm setting the
authorization key in the header,
and I'm just saying it's a JSON.
And then I'm
creating this field.
And then, within--
sorry-- this array
is a set of the registration
IDs and then the data.
And the data is the message
that I'm going to send,
and the registration IDs
is just the JSON array
of all those registration
ID that I want to send to.
And then, it's as
simple as cURL.
Anybody use cURL?
Familiar with it?
So cURL is just a great
way of calling URL.
So cURL here, I just specified
the URL I want to call.
I'm posting.
Here's the headers that
I created, static blast,
and here is my fields
of my actual data,
and I'm telling FCM to send
that message to those people,
and that's it.
That's all it does.
It's very, very simple.
And that's what
gives me the website
that we just saw a moment ago.
And in my app, I'm just
linking the same library
as I was using
for notifications.
So in this app, when this app
receives the notification,
I've tied my watch to this
phone, so notifications
on this phone--
sorry, on this tablet will
also show up on my watch.
And as a result, I received
the notification on my watch.
That's how easy it is to
build a very basic application
with Cloud Messaging.
Now, of course, if you want
to get a little bit more
sophisticated, you can do so.
I just got another "someone
has broken into your house."
So, for example, if
you want to build
a more sophisticated
application, maybe one that
uses topics, maybe one that
use the location of users,
that's entirely up
to you at this point.
Because you have this
API on the back end
that you can use to talk to
Firebase Cloud Messaging,
it's up to you how to do that.
And that was the
idea that we said,
like we have notifications
that has this console that
has tools and analytics to
drive what you're going to send.
We also wanted to give
flexibility to developers
so that you can build a
service-- if we can switch back
to slides now, please--
so that you can build
a service yourself that
intelligently manages
the communications to developers
based on how you want.
to do it.
And that's the idea behind
Firebase Cloud Messaging
and the idea behind
Firebase Notifications.
We wanted to give
you tools that you
can use to build notifications,
real time notifications, stuff
that driven by analytics
or a programmable API,
where you can build your
own infrastructure to send
notifications to you end users.
And that's it.
That's the brief talk
I wanted to give you.
Here's how Notifications works.
Here's how Cloud
Messaging works.
Here's how to build a simple
server for Cloud Messaging.
So I've got some time for some
questions if anybody has any.
At the front here.
Just wait for the mic there.
They're floating around.
I just got a third
notification that "someone's
broken into my house."
[CHUCKLING]
AUDIENCE: Hello, sir.
My question is
what's the difference
between the GCM and the FCM?
LAURENCE MORONEY:
That's a great question.
So just to repeat
the question, what's
the difference between GCM,
Google Cloud Messaging,
and FCM, FIrebase
Cloud Messaging?
So FCM grew out of GCM.
There's no great difference
between them at the moment.
So GCM was what we had first.
And then when we released
Firebase earlier this year,
we migrated the
namespaces from GCM,
from Google Cloud Messaging
into Firebase Cloud Messaging.
As we go forward, when
we add new features,
we'll add them to
Firebase Cloud Messaging,
not necessarily to
Google Cloud Messaging.
So we recommend that
people migrate over to FCM.
When it comes to the back-end
infrastructure and everything
that I've showed, they're
pretty much identical.
The URL that I gave for the
endpoint you probably saw
was FCM, not GCM.
But other than that,
they're identical.
But my recommendation would
be that as we move forward,
we're moving forward with
Firebase Cloud Messaging.
And I'd recommended that
you migrate to that.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Thank you.
And I also want to
ask does the FCM--
can work well in China?
LAURENCE MORONEY:
So as of right now,
Firebase, everything but
notifications and Admob
is really aimed at the
international market.
So if you're building
international applications,
that's Firebase Cloud Messaging
and Firebase Notifications
included.
It's really designed for that.
We're continuing to work on
it for the Chinese market,
but we don't have any time
frame or anything like that yet.
Sorry.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: So do we have data
after average [INAUDIBLE]
about the Firebase
Notifications?
So we have been using
this app for [INAUDIBLE],
but when we're sending--
we found that it's
actually not 100% message
that we send can successfully
reach users [? overall. ?]
So I just want to know
what's your average reach
rate about this?
LAURENCE MORONEY: I don't
have an average number,
but we found that when it's
not 100% reaching mobile,
it's usually-- it's a
disconnected device.
So the [INAUDIBLE] that we give
or the the numbers that we give
are for connected devices.
So if the notification's
sent, and at the point
it's sent the device is
disconnected, of course,
it's not going to
receive it right away.
When it comes back
online, it's usually
within about four weeks.
If it comes back online
within those four weeks,
then it maintains the same
SLA that they should receive
the notification in short time.
But I have noticed somewhat of
a dropoff when the initial one
was sent if the
device was offline,
that it doesn't seem to
be quite as reliable when
the device comes back
online, and that's something
that we're working on.
But I don't have an average
number or anything like that.
So that's one we talked
about like it receiving
in a very short time, that's
for actually connected devices.
AUDIENCE: So basically, we
keep sending in four weeks
until [INAUDIBLE]?
LAURENCE MORONEY: Correct.
Correct.
I mean, as you saw when was like
doing the message that you saw
the time to expire was four
weeks, you could change that,
but that's typically
how it works.
Any other questions?
OK, well-- oh,
we've got one here.
AUDIENCE: In the
Firebase Notifications,
you had a target.
So based on the type of
audience [INAUDIBLE],
how is that target identified?
LAURENCE MORONEY: So--
AUDIENCE: Is it something that
we can also control and see,
OK, this one gives
me better target.
This one gives me
better [INAUDIBLE],
something like that
we can think of that?
LAURENCE MORONEY: Yes.
So you can define your target
based on an audience defined
in Google Analytics--
sorry, in Firebase Analytics.
So, for example, you
could set an audience
in Firebase Analytics
to be people
who've made an in-app
purchase in the last 30 days.
And you can maybe
set another audience
to people who made an in-app
purchase in the last 60 days.
You can send a notification
to each of these
and then analyze the performance
of that notification.
So it's up to you to
define the audience,
and that can be done
using analytics.
Any last questions?
Nope?
Going, going.
Oh, we got one here, sorry.
AUDIENCE: I joined in the
middle, but my questions was,
if I were developing a
cross-platform application
using PhoneGap or
something, then
is it useful for iOS or Apple
the same code notification?
LAURENCE MORONEY: So if you're
using something like PhoneGap,
I'm really not familiar
with how you would do
the notifications in Firebase.
Sorry.
But we do support notifications
in Cloud Messaging
across all three platforms.
And that's iOS,
Android, and the WAN.
With PhoneGap, I think you write
it in one like C# or something
and then cross-compile
it to others.
I'm not familiar with
that for notifications.
Sorry.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Well,
in that case, xie xie ni.
Thank you very much.
And if you have any questions,
come see me afterward.
[APPLAUSE]